the first question i wanted to throw at
you guys which i kind of alluded to
earlier was
um
are dating apps a waste of time like are
are they all stump grinders all they are
you know like disgusting like you're not
going to get any any results they're not
going to match with you like what's your
experience been from that angle
i mean i'd kick things off with that um
you know in my experience i would say it
depends on two factors right it depends
on um what particular apps you're using
and then two um you know what is your
level of skill in making it work for you
cool so you know depending on your
personality type like if you're more of
that more kind of alpha playboy type of
individual then something like a
match.com is probably not going to be
better for you right or like a christian
mingle or a jade because those are
definitely a lot more
um
monogamous traditional relationship
oriented type sites um or apps versus
other sites which are going to be a lot
more conducive to your personality style
if you want to just like have a lot more
dates and you know get out and have a
bit more fun so your things like bumble
and tinder um and then of course i
i still would consider this site to be
part of the general dating app sphere
but it's kind of in its own category
which is going to be a site kind of like
seeking which is one of those where um
you know everyone that says oh there's
no such thing as different different
quality girls but i mean the question i
wanted to ask was like let's say on a
scale of one to ten with like you know
10 being bombshell and one being a c
donkey uh or some grinders
as the irishman would call it um
like what are you finding on average on
dating sites that you're generally
connecting with when you're going out
with them like we talking sevens eight
sixes like what are you dealing with
yeah it's a mix but i'll say the ab the
general average which is kind of like
the general average of life is you're
gonna be generally going between the the
five to like you know lower tier eight
range that's going to be your general
curve um the exception of that rule
obviously is gonna be sight like seeking
where there's gonna be a lot of tens and
nines on that site just it's overflooded
but that again that's its own kind of
separate bubble but as far as the
general dating app space uh because part
of my job going on consulting people is
i just got everything and was just
hopping on everything and seeing the
general space you're getting between the
the five to two to eight range on there
and then of course you get a couple of
uh you know your your nines are still
sprinkled okay so i mean like we're not
talking some grinders like our friend
posted in the comments as soon as i
generated the event from your experience
jaren what do you what do you see from
your angle because i mean you're in um
southwestern u.s you travel a lot you
know it's the latin america so what's
your experience been with uh women what
they look like
it really depends on the app and it
depends on the market so um as was just
mentioned uh for seeking for example you
will get like the eights nines tens but
i found i always use a mind game what i
call the pain in the ass factor so yeah
i can get those
uh but it's gonna be a lot more effort
and then usually on the on the back end
it's not gonna be as much fun i'm not
going to get as much out of it i'll have
to constantly be on the entire time and
i usually kind of like to chill when i
have my experiences so
so i can go for the eight nines tens on
seeking but there's gonna be a lot more
work involved and maybe the return is
not necessarily what what i'd want to
what i want to put in on the front end
so i find so if i think correctly what
you're basically saying is that you'd
prefer a pleasant seven than a
ten
yeah um i usually date in this six seven
eight range um just real nice pleasant
feminine fun girls um i've broken down
the community how i set up my profile
i'm a digital marketer by trade so i set
it down just like an inbound sales
funnel it's right on did you ever read
the book this is the experience i'm
sorry did you ever read the book inbound
marketing uh no i need to add that to my
reading list i believe uh it's old it's
about 10 years old but but it kind of
sets the mindset in
from the marketing frame of things you
know with business but you can also
apply the same concepts to
you know drawing traffic and you know
when it comes to ladies too right
yeah and that's essentially what i do so
i craft it like an offer just like
you're you're selling any goods or
services online uh you know swipe right
here's what you're gonna get i usually
do like 420 sunset snuggles um in
spanish i'll do um the translation of it
and i'll say a serenade if you're lucky
and culturally they all kind of know
what that means it already kind of sets
the tone i put my instagram right there
and then usually uh i've found in this
market that bumble's the best there's a
what in the us it's usually kind of
later 20s early 30s but here it runs a
wide range and they're usually more
professional girls
so i know on bumble here when i swipe
right that i'm gonna i'm gonna get the
match and that's just because
i'm in a different foreign market where
i believe my
smb is perceived higher than what it
would be elsewhere if i were in la i
would not i would not have this success
to be forthcoming um
all right so let me throw that question
over them yeah
okay
yes so you swipe yeah the offer is there
and when they match they already know
what they're going to get so usually
you'll have a stack of matches
we'll uh save the strategies for like
when we kind of dive down the rabbit
hole a little bit more um
so
what's your experience been because
you're in northeastern u.s
um what are you like 29 28 i'll be 30 in
february
look young man so what's your experience
been with dating women in your city like
are we talking sevens eight nines like
yeah i would echo the sentiments with uh
my other gentleman on the panel here i
mean it's i would say between that five
and you know low eight range
um
but we know like the top tier nine out
of ten women from a look standpoint are
just
not really on the apps i mean they
probably were and i think they were
during the pandemic as a function of
for attention right because they're not
going out to bars and parties and
getting hit up by guys so it's just that
extra validation that they wanted they
couldn't get out in public
i mean to answer the question though of
are they a waste of time the simple
answer is no um they are and i will
always say this they are a useful tool
but they shouldn't be the only tool on
your belt um and the three the three
major pros that i see and i have cons as
well for apps but when it comes
particularly for guys the first one is
just a pure volume standpoint so if you
wanted to approach say a hundred women
let's say you approached a woman at a
rate of one check every five minutes it
would take you like eight or nine hours
to get to 100 or take you all day you
can do that on a dating app approach as
in like swipe on a chick left or right
um or you can swipe right
in that in five minutes or ten minutes
right the second one is you have a
general understanding or there's a
certain degree of certainty that women
on dating apps are not in relationships
and they're the context is proper
they're looking for dating romance
relationships etc so you're not getting
the i have a boyfriend excuse or
whatever that might be
and i think a third one which is really
huge that that renegade wingman talks
about a lot is the importance of
text game and because the vast majority
of our interactions
whether it's personal relationships
friendships family even work at this
point is all through text 99 of all our
interactions are text so if you don't
know how to communicate over text
message if you don't know how to
properly convey tone or to flirt or to
be funny it's it's really tough out
there so it really puts you in the arena
to
expand your volume get comfortable
texting and then getting often setting
dates through the phone which whatever
you guys should be doing and then also
the proper context of you know those
basic high level objections of boyfriend
husband relationship you're not really
seeing that a lot okay cool cool cool
all right
stump grinder talk to me brother
yeah well my my experience is um
any girl you meet
in real life that you match with is at
least at least
half a point to one and a half points
below what she looks like on the app so
if you match with an eight she's either
going to be a seven and a half or a
six and a half there's no tens they're
going to be they're gonna be eight and a
half or eight it's it's it's just a fact
of it and again
you have to realize that these apps are
products and their business model is to
keep you on there as long as possible
their
business model is not to get you matched
and send you into happily ever after
they got to keep you on there so a
little trick that i use is i moderate my
parameters every now and then so if you
go into your um
your tinder account and you adjust the
mileage and you adjust the age what will
happen is it'll start throwing girls
that are in that new mileage in that new
age range up to you so sometimes i'll
live it out to 30 miles
next evening i'll bring it down to 15
and it'll start throwing up a lot more
girls um within that radius
and just to you know reinforce what moth
said about wingman is
since i started since i took his advice
on board to inject more of your
personality into your text game things
just took off exponentially for me
because i just you know i started being
me instead of you know hey if you ask a
girl how was your weekend
that'll dry her up quicker than the
sahara desert
i mean it is
it's like how's it going how's your
weekend i mean
yeah how was work today that's literally
saying can i bore you to death please
can i be your best friend
can i be yeah can i be your best friend
and if if you okay because this sense
when you're able to drop jokes with
sarcasm some of your personality in
there it's conveying that you're
confident and you really don't
you know and sometimes i will post my
greatest hits in the group and
one girl she said she said i'm looking
for something long-term and serious and
she'll match straight away because i
responded with have you tried a 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage
didn't like that at all and other girls
are like lighting up thinking that's
hilarious and they're like oh you're
funny so again you've got to have your
personality in there yeah it's a good
thing to just it's a good thing to
disqualify them though so i'll ask those
direct questions right up in the front
and like hey in a good mood or a bad new
bad mood tonight like what the hell are
you talking about like all right well
you're a bad mood
yeah if if she's she's like oh what you
thinking when you know what you're
thinking hottie you're like all right
this chick is
in a good mood i'm in a good mood and
then again sell the experience and an
addendum to the location thing
if you ever like start getting kind of
lowered down your your stack you notice
that girls are like fives and fours
if you have the premium version of the
app drop it in the market where you know
you're just going to blow the sexual
market competition out of the water like
i don't want to name my place but like
like dirty like really gross latin
american cities that i know like the
people i live with tell me don't ever go
there right all right i'll draw i'll
drop it right there
i'll get boosted right back to the top
you don't have to swipe or like them and
then you go back to your market and
you'll notice that the the does that
actually boost your value
i've seen it yeah that's that's actually
a really clever trick the interesting
clever way yeah
hack the algorithms all right so jason i
don't know if you caught the early bit
before you popped in but the question to
like kind of kick this off was as soon
as i created this event you know there's
somebody that just you know slammed in
the comments and just stripped all over
the place saying something to the effect
of don't even bother the women there are
gross blah blah blah sort of thing or
they're very low quality or some
combination of that so what's your
experience been with women using dating
apps where you live
uh so
i guess i i mean i'll give you guys my
experience and the the gals i'm dating
are
i mean
this could sound crazy because you guys
see me on here and you're like this dude
uh i dated three gals one's a current
model there two other were four models
and i'm not like
i'm six feet tall with a pair of boots
on right so it's not like i'm some chad
you know
ripped with six-pack abs and all that
nonsense um
but and a lot of the gals updated too
are
you know they're they're business owners
uh i've dated some doctors uh and i
think that's
one of the things i found is um
at least with the the gals i date
typically i'm dating those
kind of higher level professional folks
if that makes sense yeah uh because you
guys know they date across and they they
date up they don't date down
so there's a lot of really great
beautiful women who are very successful
that are just not gonna date
you know
average dudes
well that's the biggest complaint that a
lot of like university educated
professional women have is that they
have a hard time finding successful guys
that
you know can satisfy the whole hypergamy
curve right
yeah and that's where the different
sites come into play because different
girls are looking for different things
on different sites whereas you get a lot
of girls that are saying hey you know i
want to go on the bumble sites because
i'm looking for
you know i don't want to deal with the
typical tinderbros so i want like a
little bit more of an established guy
that's what pushes a lot of girls over
to like match.com or like the seeking
which is like hey we want guys that we
know are like well established and like
how they go about trying to lock down
those established guys that's a little
bit different but um just as far as like
you know knowing where the fish are
going that's very very important to your
strategy of like okay what type of girl
am i trying to attract am i trying to
attract the girls i just want to kind of
like hang out and have fun because i've
met a lot of um you know girls
especially during the pandemic right i'm
23 years old i'm bored at home
all right yeah let me go on some dating
apps and let me just you know see who's
around and who's interesting and wound
up uh having that work out really well
for me uh 2020 is a very productive year
but um again you have to understand
where exactly are the types of uh girls
that you're looking for what are they
going for so when you are on apps don't
just be on apps and just be like all
right you know i'm swiping left and
swiping right like take some mental
notes like hey these are the type of
girls that i typically seem to be
running on this particular platform let
me go bounce over to hinge and see what
type of girls are on there i would not
recommend it because the typical
demographic on hinge is um pretty
extreme but you know um again you don't
know that until you start what is the
hinge
like uh demographic if you can't explain
it because i'm not on dating apps so i'm
just trying to get it's what you the
nightmare stories of what you think the
typical girls on dating app like troll
type individuals there typically are a
lot of them are very very prevalent on
on hinge so
you only get like 10 a day too so i like
efficiency so right for ones like tender
bumble like
dating apps is they are quite efficient
i mean i started using them in the early
2000s with like the whole lava life and
limewire was it limewire or
lemon tonic or some like that
early early days and i always found them
very very efficient but it was just like
an add-on to what you were doing
right i mean it's like during 2020 when
i mean i've you know met some girls in
the world before but when things first
started kind of locking down right i was
using the apps uh i took like some notes
and just was breaking down some of the
statistics and so the first month i was
uh on those apps uh i had conversations
with 246 girls
so 246 girls right that's a lot of
conversational experience that i'm
getting and gaining right there that was
just like text conversation yep just
text conversation and then usually 146
turned into an actual face-to-face
meetup so that was the unique and
interesting part because with 2020 i
want i got a lot more exposure because
everyone was there because there was a
lockdown but a lot more people were very
hesitant right because it's like well
it's corona we're not sure if we can
like go outside or for amazon packages
or like gonna poison us so of those 246
i wound up actually meeting up with uh
18 that first month a couple i met up
with a couple months later but
that's pretty consistent you know with
your experiences like that's exactly my
246 matches you know you meet about 18
face-to-face
uh i i've been a little bit different
where
i'll because i'm basically about one in
ten
yeah yeah
i'm running probably about 30 probably
about 30 but i don't spend most of my
time on apps so for me
i love going out to you know texas is
open
i mean texas has been open for like a
year
so we're i'm i'm out in the clubs i'm at
bars i'm you know hosting you know our
real estate events and all that stuff so
i meet a lot of folks that way
um
but i have noticed the rate of attrition
is much lower obviously on the dating
apps right because you're just paul says
this right you're just an avatar like
you're just some like
you're just a random picture yeah you're
like a digital offer
you're a potential experience and if you
view the sexual marketplace it literally
when you're on an app it is the actual
sexual marketplace on a platform yeah
and you were looking at potential offers
and view it like an auction when i go to
my bumble stack and there's 200 of them
i will look at the 20 that are most
interested respond to them and usually
before i start work for the day before 8
or 9 pm i can have a couple lined up for
the day accounting for flakes and
guaranteed to have something that night
and and you can get really efficient at
it if you start viewing it literally
it's just an auction of the potential
inbound offers and the m and as you're
responding to 20 she's also responding
to 20. so it's just it's it's like when
you look at a stock trading floor you're
all trying to get in your bids and
when the music stops
whoever's gonna end up with whoever i i
i find out if it's like a last-minute
hail mary in mexico by 8pm everyone's
kind of locked in their plans for the
night and if i go on to 8 p.m there will
be there will be inbound offers of girls
who had plans canceled didn't fall
through
whatever happened during the day whereas
earlier they weren't interested 8 p.m is
the hour for that yeah and it starts you
start to learn your marketplace and know
how to guide it efficiently and it's
really gamified the space i mean as i
tell you
i tell my clients all the time it's like
look all tinder did was it globalized
and popularized the game smash or pass
and just brought it to everybody so
because i mean that's really what it is
right it's like smash pass pass smash
fast and so now it's gamified it to that
level so i think that's where there's a
little bit of a disconnect uh between a
way a lot of guys that experience a lot
of frustration
with dating apps where they view it
again we're not saying you know solely
do this 100 because i'm sure pretty much
everyone here like it's a maybe 10 to
maybe 20 at the most of any of our
activity in the dating world but at the
same time it is a very good way for you
to meet people get a lot of experience
but i think a lot of times they don't
realize guys don't realize the
gamification aspect of it so they take
it a little bit too serious a little bit
too personal rather than having a little
bit of like hey you know it's kind of a
game and i get you know my prize of this
game is like you know to meet someone up
in person
you